welcome to this first session of the one
month program
on omits logic data science in today's
session
our team will be sharing information
examples
and overview of omics logic training
resources
designed for anyone to learn data
science for biomedical data
as seen in application to projects
sourced from
current topics in biomedical research
my name is beepsha biswas and i am the
omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interactions with
thousands of users that are part
of our bioinformatics community managed
by
pine biotech let me start by introducing
pine biotech the company behind omix
logic
share with your details about the
upcoming omics logic programs and
explain how the training resources we
will
discuss today will be used in the
upcoming data science training program
comics logic is a program for
bioinformatics training
that was developed in collaboration
between pine biotech
and the tauber bioinformatics research
center
what we will discuss today and
throughout this program
is a result of hard work by an amazing
team
led by company co-founders dr
alfred tauber and dr leonid brotzky
dr alfred tober comes from a medical
background and has
extensive expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation
and has been recognized internationally
for his generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives
that support data science training and
applications in medicine
dr leonid brodsky is the director of the
tobor bioinformatics research center
at university of haifa and is an expert
in bioinformatics and biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics and over
the course of his career
has developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches to biomedical data analysis
the rest of the team you see here
includes bioinformaticians computer
scientists
and also our trainers and some of our
team will be presenting today
over the course of the past several
years our team has been collaborating
with a number of
academic institutions around the world
that have participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design as a result
the omics logic programs have been
thoroughly evaluated and are known
to lead to excellent outcomes
importantly the programs are designed to
support students with minimal
bioinformatics background including
biology and biomedical studies majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics data science
and biomedical research the goal
of the omics logic programs is to
provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors
and pure example developing a growing
community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds
to develop novel and independent
research using latest technology
in life and data sciences
this program is designed to offer an
introduction to statistical
analysis and machine learning and a
broad overview of
technologies and project examples to
learn about
and develop practical data science
skills using user-friendly
cloud technologies as well as r and
python coding
in this month program you will have the
opportunity
to interact and collaborate with an
international team of experts
specialized in the areas of
bioinformatics and data-driven research
let me introduce you to the program
mentors and the speakers of today's
session
elia brodsky is our ceo and co-founder
his experience in research in academia
has led to many research labs and
university collaborations
that has been recognized for the
simplified approach to
omics analysis for education
dr harpreep core is our omics logic
trainer and expert by information
who will mentor sessions and guide you
through the program
her era of specialization is cancer
genomics
dr mohit mazumdar has a phd in
computational biology and over 10 years
of experience working with
industry and academia with this
i would like to pass over to elia
brodsky
to continue this session thank you
everyone
thank you and welcome back everyone to
the first session of this data science
program so
just to explain how these sessions are
going to work for the remainder of the
program
we're going to combine interactive
sessions on zoom
and in a little bit you will see how we
will try to make them
interactive we will actually ask you
questions and you will hopefully
have the chance to uh reply and
contribute to
what we understand about our users we'll
also introduce
some of the self-self-guided study
materials that we'll be using throughout
this program as well as those that are
available apart outside of this
program so we'll describe some of the
resources that you'll be
gaining access to and we'll talk also
about
the platforms designed to make this
experience seamless because we see
one of the major obstacles for people to
start with data science
is to be able to start quickly and focus
on the topics and the projects that they
are interested in
instead of doing the traditional hello
world
and then getting stuck with some of the
next steps so we are hoping to
streamline
simplify and accelerate your process
into getting started with data science
and getting started with bioinformatics
so i'll give you a little bit of a
taste of that today and hopefully
throughout the program you'll become
more and more proficient
using some of these tools
okay so one of the obvious questions
that a lot of people
ask is regarding the bioinformatics
and the data science domains themselves
so what are the similarities and what
are
the differences between these two
domains
data science is a fairly new term
that recently emerged and has become
very
popular and bioinformatics is a term
that has been around for a while now and
so
our company specializes in
bioinformatics we
provide a number of different resources
as well as training
programs for bioinformatics and this is
one of our programs and this program is
called
data science for biomedical data
so what are the difference the
differences
especially in biology and the medical
science community
there is a lot of interest in data
science and so when
people with background in life sciences
with an interest in medical applications
of data
analysis come and ask
well what's the difference between data
science and what has always been around
which is bioinformatics
you tend to start questioning well
what's the difference between
these two and what are the specific
details of each one
so when we talk about data science
it's important to understand that data
science
is the science of data and
one of the first requirements when you
talk about
data is to specify what specific domain
is it going to be related to so you do
have to understand that each domain
has a lot of experience and has a lot of
knowledge that is required to be able to
function in that domain
efficiently so that's why the
specialization
that part the pink part is very
important so in bioinformatics that
specialization
is biology in data science that is
fairly
agnostic so it could be anything so
really
the main difference between
bioinformatics and data science
is that specialization the focus on
biological data it's important that when
we think about
what a bioinformatician does and what a
data scientist does
they do very similar things for example
you have to
possess domain specific data processing
and
quality check abilities you have to
have a general sense of how to do
specific data transformations and
filtering
understanding where the data is coming
from
it's also important to understand that
there are different types of
informational data visualization and
reporting tools
that are going to be very domain
specific if we for example
talk about specific types of
visualization and we'll give some
examples and do those together
when we talk about general statistics or
clinical reporting for example or
specific types of information carried
in specific types of applications of
bioinformatics right
so a lot of this also is inside a domain
specific a range of apis
databases file types etc
so all of these specific types of
applications
are very important to understand when we
start talking about
the differences and the similarities
between bioinformatics and data science
now as all of you are joining from many
different
areas many different countries many
different backgrounds
we have to find a common ground and an
ability to be able to
discuss the specifics of getting started
with data science
in this domain of biology
and life sciences and so that's why
we're starting here
from bioinformatics and data science
now as i mentioned data science is
the study of data it involves developing
methods of recording
storing and analyzing data to
effectively extract
useful information so the goal of data
science is to gain
insights and knowledge from any type of
data
both structured and unstructured which
leads us to the following question
what is the difference between
structured
and unstructured data and then more
specifically we'll talk about
what does that mean in the context of
life sciences
so let's talk about the process of data
and how that data evolves and changes
forms
as we go through this process so the
objective
is to gain insight or be able to
act on that insight based on
data so by analyzing data and
understanding what's in the data
we can take action that process
goes from raw unstructured data
which we can think about zeros and ones
so binary
way of storing that data all the way
to then transforming that data into
tables structured data maybe those
tables are
annotated they have some labels so they
help us
understand in human terms what it is
related to
understanding relationships between
different elements
within those tables within the
structured data we can map
different types of relationships and the
connections between those different
elements
and between their annotation typically
results
in some kind of an insight for example
what is important what are some of the
proportions
how do they relate each other and what
are some patterns that allow us to track
that relationship ultimately then
we get to this ability to act
upon what we understand if it is
understanding
and containing that knowledge
or potentially developing a process
and that process helps automate
and prepare the data for intuitive
analysis and for insightful application
of that knowledge
so the process goes from unstructured
data for example
we can talk about in normal types of
data we can talk about media posts
emails online reviews videos and images
or speech and sounds so really data that
is contained
in some kind of a digital format but it
is not
easy to search and analyze as we
start working with that data we start
adding some labels and maybe meta
information to that data so that helps
us
organize things by folders maybe we
create some kind of a data schema maybe
we start
organizing our emails in inboxes etc
and then eventually we can prepare
structured data so that could be
google sheets or that could be excel
sheets or that could be a database
and that database becomes accessible
that database
becomes searchable so it is ready for
insights so let's think about this
together let me ask you
the following questions to illustrate
this process
so number one what is your current level
of education
so i know that many of you have already
answered that
in this chat and we'll see
how this is very difficult to manage so
people would say
i have a phd i'm a phd scholar
i am from this country and i specialize
in this type of research
but to help us structure this data let's
provide you with a schema so number one
is you're in high school number two
you have an undergraduate degree number
three
you'll have some form of graduate degree
and number four
you have a post graduate degree so
please
answer in the chat box
all right excellent so many of you have
answered
and as you can see looking in the chat
box you can see
a stream of answers and those answers
wrench between
numbers as we assign to these different
options
or some people would also add some kind
of a description
so to illustrate the process
in a moment we'll be looking at how to
analyze such data and gain
insights from this data but before we do
let me ask you another question
and so the other question is why did you
expect
from this program now instead of
answering this question in the exact
same way
i will ask you to do something different
okay and this will help us think about
the structure of our data instead of
answering just
a number okay make sure that for the
second question
you are putting a number for example 2
dot whatever the answer is so for
example
why do you expect or sorry the question
should be
what do you expect from this program so
you can answer 2.1
is learn about omix data analysis 2.2
is get familiarized with data science
2.3
overview of to gain an overview of
statistical and machine learning methods
2.4 applied data science to a research
project
and then some of you might be interested
in multiple
so you will point 2.5
will be for multiple answers from this
list
all right so we have a lot of people
here today and so obviously there's will
be
a lot of different answers okay and
thank you for providing this answer
uh let's now think about how
the answers themselves can become
information right this is raw data
anyone looking at this can spot
numbers coming in on the screen you can
see
the variety of answers that are coming
in
and the variety of formats okay but
now we will try to gain insight
what does this information actually
carry okay so
the way that the unstructured data comes
in
is in the following way right so some
people
start answering early on some people are
putting in different types of answers at
different times in different formats
and then we can process this
unstructured data
and convert this into structure data
which allows us
to very simply translate the
information from that unstructured data
into some summary for example many
will answer that they would like to
apply data science to
a research project okay or for example
we can look at
all of the participants and we can see
that many
are postgraduate right and so as we
continue to
ask these types of questions and provide
the users with a schema with an
organization
of that data so that it is easy to
process
it is very easy for us to translate this
information
into an actionable type of a
resource so that's really the value
of the understanding of data structures
and preparing a format a format that is
specific to the type of interaction we
have
now this is a simple example this is
example that allows us to learn about
you
the participants of this webinar but
also for you to start thinking about
the significance of how the data is
organized
so let me ask you another question what
is
an example of unstructured data in
research
okay now you don't have to follow any
schema
this is more of a discussion so what do
you think
is a way it is one is an example
sorry of unstructured data and research
okay so someone is
answering documents or raw data let's be
more specific
so give me some example okay
non-analyzed reads okay so maybe
sequencing reads
results from experiments so direct
results from experiments
raw genomic data excellent images of
specimens
okay very good example observational
okay miley is answering soil samples
from garden
okay so soil samples of their stored
somewhere
that's interesting raw sequencing sun is
answering
uh jefflin uh jefferson sorry is saying
video okay so maybe some recording of an
experiment
okay uh clinical notes a very good
example so
this may maybe is related to
clinical research okay so literature um
any numbers generated through
experiments so raw pcr data or imaging
picture data okay
excellent okay let me ask you another
question
what is an example of actionable data
in clinical practice okay so if you
think about clinical
practice okay a clinical practice is
when an interaction happens between a
clinician
and a patient or some member of the
clinical community
and the patient can you give me an
example of
actionable data in clinical practice
okay so people are saying ehrs
uh or mri data clinical application
forms
proto okay blood pressure x-rated okay
so
exxon examples uh let's think about what
makes them actionable right so here we
were talking about
unstructured data for example we talked
about
raw sequencing reads right and then how
do we translate that
into an actionable data maybe a report
like suggested by anjali or a biomarker
suggested by anuradha right so we have a
biomarker an
indicator that is known to be associated
with some
clinical condition right so that's
really
what makes it actionable is a
studied and characterized association
okay charts and graphs okay so maybe
those are some
insights charts and graphs or some
insights and then what makes them
actionable if those insights provide
an established way to talk about
some clinical and studied condition
right so it's the association what we're
trying to say here is that
we have raw data and then we have an
association
okay let me ask you another final
question
what is an example of a data process
okay so think about those two things
that we talked about number one and
number two
we have raw data we you have a lot of
examples there in the chat
and then you have some actions that
could be made based
on analysis of that data so give me some
examples
of a data process okay
so filling data genome assembly
charts and graphs or making charts and
graphs multiple sequence alignment
okay replication okay
so let's think about what other
processing we could think of in the
context of this life science data
okay excellent so genova is saying
differential
expression analysis or qsar
okay uh so
variant calling chromatogram file
trimming microarray okay so again
what's important here is to remember
that there is a difference
between for example microarray
microarray could be
the type of data and a process and so
variant calling is a great example right
because you have a lot of raw data you
have a lot of aligned
reads and then you're actually calling
you're looking for specific types of
variants so we'll talk about that in a
second but
as you can see from this kind of a
thought process really the objective of
this data science in biological data
in life sciences especially in the
domain of
this biomedical research is to be able
to
incorporate the data science principles
into the processing organization
analysis and insights
that come from associations between
clinical and omics data
between the raw data and the structure
data to provide us with
insights and the objective a lot of
times
is to really provide insights about
diagnostics and about selection
or development and design of therapeutic
interventions
so that's what our program is going to
be focused on
and that's how the omics logic data
science program
is going to be different from some of
your other data science
resources and programs out there instead
of just talking about
general data which we could be talking
about surveys
which is what we did today or we could
be talking about
analysis of sentiment why and how do
people feel about different things
in this program we're going to be
talking about omics data
and specifically we'll be focused on the
association the relationships between
clinical phenotypes and their utility
in different types of examples and
on the other side the unstructured data
that comes out from different
types of techniques to generate data
in life sciences and that will include
particularly
the omics type of information so omix
we'll talk about that in a second what
type of data that is
and what kinds of insights that could
provide us with
now for all of you that have submitted
your answers
about your background about your
location maybe even about your current
institution we ask all of you
to take a look at the introduction to
bioinformatics course
this course is not only a good overview
that could be very useful for those of
you that are interested in
bioinformatics
but also it includes a survey and that
survey
is going to structure this information
for us to be able to analyze and
understand
the interest in the community in
bioinformatics
and also provide you with some
applications of bioinformatics in
different domains
so all of you if you could please look
in the chat there's the link to this
course
introduction to bioinformatics it's a
free course so anyone could take this
and in the first lesson of that course
you have the survey
and that survey will provide us with
this important information
because we are constantly developing
ways and tools
to make bioinformatics more accessible
and that is actually our company mission
and the way we think about
bioinformatics is that
from becoming a very niche area
of life sciences very unique and
specific domain in life sciences
it is actually becoming an important
part
of skill sets that are needed
across the whole range
of jobs and positions
within the life science community from
people that actually generate data in
the labs
okay so lab technicians and people that
deal with samples their objective as we
move into the future of life sciences
is to generate more and better data they
have the ability to control quality they
have the ability to control the
annotation and the details that they
provide with the data that's coming out
from those labs
and so it's very important to be able to
understand
the use cases of bioinformatics and the
different skills and
be able to be proficient with analysis
and handling of that data
obviously the people that deal with data
have to understand how that data is
generated
and how to use it at the other side of
it so they're really the link
between the people that generate the
data and the people that use this data
and many times what the normal
way that you kind of look at
bioinformatics from
a perspective of just an analyst
is specializing in the processing and
the insights part of it
but i think that as bioinformatics
continues to expand
it becomes more and more practical and
so people have to understand how data is
generated and how
it is used in the context of making
clinical decisions
and so that's the objective is really to
provide
bioinformatics training to find a way to
look at biology as a data
science and to understand how it helps
us
provide how it helps us make those links
between the way the data is generated
the way it is
analyzed and the way it is applied now
for any one of you that is joining us
for the first time
i also want to request that you not only
look
at the introduction to bioinformatics
course but you also start
building up your profile okay again this
is something that you can start doing
for free
but it's an important part of letting
the world know
who you are and why you're doing what
you're doing and i think it also
can explain how important it is for
those of you that are going to continue
your journey in bioinformatics
to provide the information about
yourself in an organized way and i'll
talk a little bit more about how you can
then
build up your profile and advance
your position within this world of
bioinformatics
so first of all there are a lot of
tools to make your bioinformatics
profile
more uh more stand out so make it
more accessible more visible more
searchable okay
what's an important part is to name who
you are
so give it a full name it's important to
put up a face a picture an avatar
whatever it is
and then to start developing that
profile so really
to make mention of your publications
to make mention of your social media
profiles
to join different groups by interests
and to start showcasing your skills and
your projects and so this program will
actually help you
make sure that your profile becomes more
searchable
more visible and stand out from the rest
and that's one of the objectives that we
have here is to help those that are
starting with bioinformatics perhaps
coming from
other life science domains generate a
profile
that stands out and that is impactful
okay so the way we will do this is we
will
track your activity throughout this
program so as you're joining
this program create your profile you
start
filling out different surveys start
completing different courses
that process is going to help you
really showcase what skills you're
gaining and what topics you are covering
in your in the process and so here are
some good
examples from people that have recently
joined a program
and are starting to make some progress
so you can see for example
april jane uh here filled out all of her
social media profiles and
she's joined the comics logic
biomechanical data
you can see marek for example or you can
see
hasan here every person has the ability
to really build up their profile and so
what is the ultimate outcome from this
process of building up your profile
the final outcome is that after
completing this full program
you are going to build up a profile
that stands out how will that happen so
for example here you can see
mikhail he joined the program he has
completed multiple programs and now has
certificates
on his profile and he is also
one of the top profiles on our
leaderboard so you can see that our
company runs a leaderboard of people
that complete courses and do different
activities throughout the program
and as a result you are
more easily found within this community
now also
for those of you that are doing this uh
you will be able to provide
some feedback on the program and will
actually highlight your uh
project and your responses to the
different questions
and i think it's very important for us
to build up this community to
learn from each other learn how do you
leverage these
resources and what you can do with them
and so many of the participants from our
previous programs have
gone on to become professionals in data
science and in bioinformatics and so i
hope that for all of you joining us here
for the first time
this is the journey that you're
embarking on with us together and with
our whole community
and to do that effectively we will
uh we will try to
make all the efforts on our side
to help you get to that level so
again i see that some people are
requesting those links again thank you
beeps for posting that
okay so let's talk about omix data and
let's talk about
what are some of the challenges and
opportunities
with big data and why data science is
even needed
especially in the domain of biomedical
research
so as you know there is an exponential
growth
in the resources that are being made
available on
public repositories and what that means
is that
we are sitting on this valuable
resource which is unanalyzed data so
even though
you can see here the number of
genbank sequences and the number of
users
the number of users is starting to
overtake
the number of published ncbi resources
but also you can see that in the end
a lot of the data the raw data that is
being posted
on these repositories is actually not
completely analyzed and
annotated and i think it's both a
challenge
for us as a community to gain insights
from this
unanalyzed data but also it's an
opportunity because
as these are unreported insights from
data that already exists on public
domain repositories
we can contribute and we can gain
insights develop novel hypotheses
and also be able to handle this data in
a very
uh efficient way to enrich
and empower our research
now one of the challenges with big data
is that this data has
properties that require efficient tools
to process analyze gain insights and
structure the data
efficiently because this data is
constantly changing
it comes with a variety of formats and
it has
very specific domain questions and
technical variation that we need to know
how to deal with
so for example let's take the example of
next generation sequencing how many of
you here
are familiar with next generation
sequencing
okay if you are familiar with next
generation sequencing what it is
please put in one if you are unfamiliar
with what it is
please put in two okay so number one
if you are familiar number two
if you are unfamiliar
okay excellent so i see that many of you
here
are familiar and some of you are
unfamiliar with it so let's briefly
before we go on explain
what next generation sequencing can
allow us to do
and what is this data this omics data
that could be genomics transcriptomics
epigenomics etc what can it give us
okay okay so next generation sequencing
or onyx data
as an example let's take next-generation
sequencing there
once we characterize the samples that we
have we have pictures for example here
of cells
and these pictures can help us
characterize what these cells look like
what is their shape how are they
different from other types of cells
right we can really categorize that data
now we can do this
in a simple way looking at the picture
and kind of describing it in words
or we can process these images
analyze them computationally and
generate
a lot of that data which together will
be called
phenomics okay so this is the study of
the way things are
looking and character characterized as
we look
beneath the surface besides what it
looks like on the surface
and how it functions perhaps we are
going to discover
molecular signatures of what is the
cause
to lead to this phenotype and so that
type of data can include
genomics okay in terms of genomics next
generation sequencing genomic data
can provide us insights about variants
how
we can compare dna sequences
of these cells to other normal cells
and what are the differences what are
the variants in the dna
code we can also look at this
emerging field of epigenomics and one of
the questions that epigenomics
asks is how does this
process of going from dna variants
or non-dna variants can cause
differences
in gene expression so when we talk about
the phenotypes the phenotypes are
produced by
proteins that are functional and the
cell
itself is regulated by multiple
processes and not all of these processes
are genetic they're not resulting from
changes in the dna
and so as a result we have this field of
epigenome
epigenomics it has become a prominent
part of
next-generation sequencing because we
can study the role of micrornas
non-coding rnas and all kinds of
variation
that leads to gene expression changes
but does not come from dna
now ultimately we then come to the
expression
of rna and the expression of rna could
be
mrna or non-mrna but transcriptomics
is the field that focuses on the
analysis of
mrna so a lot of times we think of mrna
as really the immediate step before
protein
translation into protein and so it's a
good proxy a good
measurement of what happens at the
protein level
so next generation sequencing is a
technology
and has specific types of machines
but those machines can produce multiple
types of
insights same data different types of
insights
so if we have multiple types of data
for or sorry one type of data for
multiple
types of insights the question is how
can we find those insights
within next generation sequencing data
so the answer is
we have to process this data
and the specific types of processing
the specific types of analysis that
translate this raw sequencing data
into tables is the process
of what we call bioinformatics pipeline
so we have to take this raw sequencing
data
and go through multiple steps to be able
to translate this data
into a particular structure okay
let's take a look at how to do this
together
beeps say if you could please post the
demo account information so people can
log into the platform
we will illustrate how to do this so i'm
just going to
pause as i go to the next slide and
please go to this link server.t
bio.info and we will take a look
at how processing is done to generate
information that could be used
for uh analysis
of this data okay so i will go to
server.tashbio.info
and you have here in the chat your
details
so you can log in okay so once you log
in
please let me know okay so once you're
logged in
you should be able to see what i am
seeing
which is the t-bioinfo areas of analysis
when you log in please put number one
in the chat box
okay for those of you getting here for
the first time you will see here
log in and you'll be able to log in okay
great so apoorv and dr hundama mustafa
great so it's great to see that you're
logged in
and you can start exploring and kind of
seeing what's available as we wait for
others to log in
once you're logged in you should also
see uh right here i see
my account but you'll be seeing info at
pine biotech so
you'll be seeing here that you are
logged in
okay did anyone else manage to log in
all right great so let me explain what
this
is this is the t-bioinfo platform
which was designed by the timber
bioinformatics research center to
simplify
processing and analysis of
large data sets like next generation
sequencing
mass spectroscopy structural data and
perform multiple types of integrations
analysis statistical analysis annotation
and also train machine learning models
so we will
talk about all of this in the context of
this data science program
okay for those of you that cannot log in
uh pizza maybe you could provide
another okay thank you so there's an
alternative account
too many people logging in at the same
time
uh is not going to work very well so
we've provided multiple
accounts so if you did not log in with
the first account try the second account
and you'll be able to see the same thing
all right so for those of you that have
logged in
you'll notice here we'll take a look
today at rna seek data so transcriptomic
data so please
look at this first section and don't
click on it just yet
click on this down arrow so once it
clicks you will see
there's a few demo options and we will
select
the first one so demo rna-seq
okay so once you're in here you'll see
that
there are number of buttons and these
buttons each represents
an algorithm this algorithm will take
the source data
and do one function okay so
typically for example the start button
will load in
all of your data so let's click on
the start in the start you will also
learn
about the next steps that need to happen
including the processing or the
pre-processing of data
the raw reads and we'll talk about this
in our next session actually in much
more detail
but first step is to do pre-processing
to
make sure that the reads are clean then
we do
mapping only on the good reads we will
do mapping on the reference genome
and then we will quantify expression
levels
so we will look at the level of
expression of genes
okay and here's an example pipeline
you can actually select trimmomatic pcr
clean
then go to bow type 2t rsm expression
table
and then end okay so i'll give you a
couple of minutes
to prepare this pipeline on your own if
you were able to create this pipeline on
your own
please put in number two so i know that
you have completed this pipeline for the
rest of you
if you're not able to do this or you're
not logged in
please review the login information
above in the chat
and we're going to try to do this
together
okay glory thank you he's completed
anyone else
okay for those of you okay all right
excellent if you you're just logging in
right now
uh you go to the areas of analysis
again here under transcriptomics
you click on the down arrow
and we're selecting this first option
rna seek
cell line project
okay so for those of you that are logged
in
how to log in so for those of you that
are not logged
in there's a password and an email
address that you can use that was posted
in the chat okay and then you
can gain access to this demo account
okay so for those of you that got to the
place where i am at
okay so you go to start
you see here an overview of three major
steps
to process next generation sequencing
transcriptomic data
and now you have to create this pipeline
okay so try to do it on your own after
you've tried to do it
on your own and we're able to create
this put number two
into the chat box if you have not been
able to do it then just give it a couple
minutes and we'll do it together
okay and thank you mustafa is helping
out here as well
for those of you that need to log in you
will have to
okay great so dr duma is in
excellent all right so let's do this
pipeline together so here we have
the button start once i click on it i
need to click on
ok adding it to my pipeline now you can
see that it is blue
the next step is to do pre-processing so
we'll use trim-a-matic which
just simply trims the reads from bad
quality and technical
sequences pcr clean
which deals with pcr bridge
amplification we'll talk a lot more in
detail about this in our next session
then we'll do mapping onto the reference
genome
you can use hysat2 if you want to go
back you right click
and you can also go to bow tie to t so
remember from the example that we saw
in the start button it was actually bow
tie to
t so it's bow tie to t is an
algorithm to apply mapping on the
transcriptome so just
the express genes okay so now we did
their preprocessing steps
our mapping and now we create the rsm
expression table
and what the rsm expression table will
do is actually
prepare a table of expression based on
how many reads were mapped to each
element genomic element on the dna which
includes
genes transcripts exons etc
so now you will have a gene expression
table
so we are done with our pipeline right
so we've taken
raw sequencing reads we process them
we've
now mapped them on to the reference
transcriptome created a gene expression
table
click on end and ok and now you will see
that there are some files that we can
work with
and now we can do downstream analysis
right so now we can
look for trends we can look for patterns
we can look for associations
only after we prepare and process this
data
so let's think about this process
that allows us to transform raw
sequencing data
into specific types of structured data
that we will be working with throughout
this program
now it's important that in every lesson
that you will find in every course that
you will find there are going to be
practical assignments
using this t-violin for platform this
platform can allow you to study
different types of omics data including
genomic data
transcriptomic data metagenomic data
and examples from all of these types of
sequencing data will be used
in the data science program as we
continue to work
throughout the program so some of the
things that we'll be doing
is processing a lot of it will be
downstream analysis so we will look at
different types of variations and we'll
try to analyze these variations
for insights into biology into the
meaning
of what the data describes okay
so as you go through this process
remember that this process
is actually describing
with color-coded maps what is the logic
behind this analysis okay so for those
of you thinking about the program
we are going to cover each one of these
steps and describe
how these steps form a logical
approach to the analysis of next
generation sequencing data the colors
help you remember what are those steps
and how those steps are logically
connected okay as you go
through each method will be explained
so there's going to be a link to the
article there's going to be an
explanation behind the principle
of why we're doing what we're doing and
if you would like to
make this a part of your own analysis
pipeline you'll have a link to
where you can download the script and
actually run it on your computer
on your server or use it on this
platform
now all of these different types of
methods
produce a variety of different outputs
and inputs for whatever next step in
your analysis
is going to be so what we're going to do
is we're going to discuss the different
formats we'll talk about
data files and data formats
that go into each one of these methods
and the different data types and outputs
that are coming out from each one of
these steps
as you practice and do a number of these
different
exercises you will see that this guided
process is going to prepare you
to be more independent and to be more
capable
at doing what you're doing so that you
can now apply
some of these methods to the data that
you
find on ncbi or maybe you generate in
your own lab
and it's important that we will also be
talking about reproducible
workflows so these reproducible
workflows are going to allow us to
share information whenever you complete
your analysis
with someone else that will ask you well
how did you actually generate this data
okay so at this moment i'm going to take
a pause
and ask if there are any questions about
what we did so far
are there any questions about what we're
doing okay so ice warrior
is asking does the knowledge about how
the raw data is converted to structured
one through this pipeline is shared in
this course yes so that is exactly the
objective
is to explain each step first of all at
a very high
conceptual level so that you understand
how the logic
puts them together and then going deeper
and deeper into each one of these
methods to understand the variation
to understand the settings to understand
the process and also understand the
objective what can you actually do with
this type of data
okay excellent question will it be
useful
for someone who is not a biology student
and someone working in software
development
so if you're working in software
development it's important to understand
that
this type of data is growing
exponentially
and as a result there's a lot of
interest in finding people that
understand
data sciences and know how to deal with
data effectively
to help analyze and extract insights
from these types of data sets
now that is your traditional
bioinformatician and
bioinformatician jobs
are you know available there's many
bioinformatics
companies and there are many companies
that are pharmaceutical companies
and a biotechnology companies that are
going to be interested
in finding someone that can deal with
this data efficiently
okay can we learn uh cad here in this
course
so the course is going to be focused on
data science so it's going to be focused
on how to take
processed data and find patterns
analyze those patterns using statistics
and machine learning
and to be able to design a data science
analysis process that is reproducible
and effective can we execute our
real-time projects using our platforms
by paying apart from this training yes
so definitely
this is a training program for those
that are interested to gain
skills and those that are interested to
complete a course
the platform itself is a research
platform and
beeps you're welcome to put a link to
the
pricing and the details about the
different research licenses
also for those interested do we have any
class for a chemistry student who wants
to jump to bioinformatics for
phd course i think this introduction is
going to be a useful
start okay so for those of you that want
to
just kind of explore before you jump
into this
i highly recommend taking some of these
courses that go from very beginner level
courses
to more and more advanced so you can see
here introduction to bioinformatics
genomics genomics one
two transcriptomics one two three and
four etc so you'll see more and more
advanced courses
as you join this program i think it's
important to get an overview of a
variety of different types of omics data
understand what's included in different
stages
and then eventually to develop a project
so the project is going to really
help you demonstrate what it is that you
want to do but also understand how it's
all
working for the specific types of
applications that you're interested in
okay currently we do not offer a course
on proteomics or metabolomics even
though there is a section
on mass spectroscopy data if you're
already
able to use this in uh if you understand
what the logic is you can use the
sections here for mass spectate
all right thank you very much for your
questions
and we will continue to talk about
these types of applications in our next
session
which is coming up very soon but let me
go back
to the presentation to kind of pick up
on where we are
after we analyze this data what are we
going to do
with the analyzed data right
so once we analyze this raw data
we have our table of expression
or we have characteristics of a protein
maybe mutations that we know of their
specific position
and function we're going to be able to
start
asking questions okay remember how we
took
the data from the chat and translated
that
into some insights and understood
proportions
between the number of participants that
have a phd that have a high school
degree or have an undergraduate degree
those are insights when we talk about
insights from big
omics data from these huge data sets
we're talking about the ability
to find relationships that can be
actionable that you can do something
about okay so in the context of biology
that means
if i understand that here we can see
mutations
on the spike glycoprotein of covet 19
and the h2 receptor i can think about
intervening in the connection between
the two and maybe blocking the virus
from
entering a cell if i understand
how there are biomarkers that can
explain differences between different
types of cancer subtypes
i can ask the question what can i do
about those genes that are overexpressed
in a particular type of a cancer if i
understand that there are specific
sequences
that are found and those sequences
annotate
or mention for me that this is the
beginning of a gene
i can find maybe a micro rna
that will bind to that region and block
expression of a gene
for those of you interested in
structural biology
i can understand the physical chemical
properties
of molecules identifying targets
for the different molecules on a protein
structure
and try docking them so that i know that
they fit well
so that their chemical properties
interact with the chemical properties
on the protein and that interaction is
strong
enough for me to understand that they
will function
and activate or deactivate some portion
of that enzyme or protein
okay so really the idea here is to learn
about
complex relationships that are becoming
very very important as we study biology
at the subcellular
level now to understand all of this
it's not enough to give you some general
information about all of these topics
what we'll do
is we'll take a number of projects
these are going to be sourced from high
impact journals peer-reviewed journals
with data sets coming from those
journals directly
and analyzed to provide us insights into
diagnostics and cancer biology
single cell and tissue composition
and microbiome and how it relates to
infection okay and yes
shayery does that full program will
include
a certificate from pine biotech but also
from the tower bioinformatics research
center
which is an academic institution okay so
as we think about these projects you
will just get an illustration
of how the different steps and aspects
of data science
fit in to help you produce meaningful
results so here are some of the skills
that you will learn
about and you will be able to apply
at the end of this program you will see
the relationship between
experimental design and data collection
as a result of understanding how the
experiment was conducted
you will see the need for pre-processing
and cleaning so that you can organize
and prepare the data for analysis
eliminating technical variation
addressing batch effects
and any kind of technical specification
of the machine and the lab where the
data came from
after that we will talk about
exploratory data analysis we'll talk
about how to see
what types of patterns and general
statistical properties
can help us understand the data we're
dealing with
and generate a hypothesis about the
different types of comparisons
or maybe specific types of data that we
have available for training
we'll talk about data mining so
oftentimes we can visualize our data and
we can also look for patterns
but there's so many patterns to look for
we really have to mine the data for
something informative and interesting so
we'll talk about different tools and
methods to do that
and how to deal with the data sets based
on
whatever our next objective is now
the process of data analysis will
include
some statistics and machine learning so
we'll talk about the difference between
traditional statistical analysis and
what is called
machine learning or deep learning when
we actually train a model
and that model can help predict or under
help us understand what's inside the
data
without necessarily understanding
exactly
what this means from a biological or a
clinical perspective so we'll talk about
some of those important things
and we'll talk about how to go from a
trained model or a statistical analysis
to inference now when we do that we'll
cover
a number of different methods and those
include
different methods of data mining and
machine learning that are becoming
commonly used
in a variety of different biomedical
research papers
bioinformatics research papers biology
research papers
and even are used at the more clinical
research level so we'll talk about
things like decision trees
and random forest linear discriminatory
analysis and stepwise lba
we'll talk about hierarchical clustering
and k-means clustering and we'll talk
about the differences and similarities
between these different types of methods
and how they can be used to gain
insights
from big data once we do that
we'll also talk about the process of
prediction or inference that is used
in the context of statistical analysis
we'll talk about the different data
types and we'll talk about
how those different data types should be
handled for us to be
confident and for us to know that the
prediction is valid
and for us to be able to explain what
this prediction means
we'll also talk about some basics about
data science where we think about the
different types of data
and the appropriate methods of
visualizing that data so that you can
present your analysis
at the end and be capable at explaining
and visualizing data effectively knowing
specific types of approaches that come
from an understanding of syntax behind
r and python so we'll cover a little bit
of both of those languages
and be able to talk about how to prepare
and work with these different types of
data
okay so i think it's very clear that
when we talk about
data from chat boxes or
emails or maybe even journal articles
it's fairly simple
but when we talk about omix data all of
these different steps
are maybe not always clear-cut and
understood by everyone
so let's take an example here's an
example
of genomic data or genetic data
from a clinical panel
designed to inform a clinician about
risk for
mutations in breast cancer
when we talk about mutations in breast
cancer probably everybody is familiar
with the brocco one mutation right so
broncho1
mutations have specific weights
that they carry from a clinical
perspective
when we want to test for those clinical
indicators using next generation
sequencing
the first step is to generate that data
so
you generate that data and that is done
in the wet lab right so from before the
wet lab
maybe a clinician assigns a patient to
this lab
and then the data is generated
after that the process of analyzing that
data
will look at the short reads that come
from a particular gene the braca one
gene
the bronco one gene will compare will be
compared
between an individual and a reference
and then the variants
that are most prominent in that sample
will be
reported and oftentimes that includes
being able to interpret what is found
because you will
oftentimes have a number of specific
rules
and guidelines to look at the source
data
look at the analyze data and prepare a
report so that is one of the things that
we will do in this program we'll
actually go through this process
of looking at the raw data looking at
the structured data
looking at those guidelines and trying
to piece all of that together
when we do that we will rely on
algorithms
okay so the important part of this data
science program
is to not only understand conceptually
but to be able to work with
algorithms tools that people have
designed
to actually extract meaningful insights
relying on a computer and so here what
we'll do
is we will take exa this is just an
example
we'll take a look at how do we take all
of the available features whether they
are variants
or whether they are genes and their
expression data
and work with algorithms that are called
greedy algorithms that help us do
feature selection so the process will be
by iterative looking at all of the
features
using statistical approach to understand
the value
that this specific feature carries in
the overall data set
and then try to maximize the separation
between
classes so that we can go through the
process of feature selection
and improve accuracy of the prediction
of our model
and so we are going to look at all of
these different steps both from a
conceptual
and a technical perspective so that
after completing this program you
yourself will be proficient
at reading interpreting and evaluating
the relationship between algorithms
data and insights
in the end you will be able to place
yourself
in a position of a clinician that is
dealing with
taking samples from a biopsy a tumor
biopsy
separating that data into data that
could
be translated into dna
variant calling okay and then compared
to your database of big data let's say
on the cancer genome atlas you have
thousands of patients
that have their tumors characterized by
different clinical phenotype
and use the analytical approaches that
we are discussing here today
to gain insights not only that you will
also be able to report your insights in
a meaningful way
to your partners that you are dealing
and collaborating with so that they
understand
what is in the data without having to
ask you
what exactly did you do so we'll learn
about some of the commonly used
approaches for bioinformatics analysis
interpretation and visualization
that will be commonly accepted by people
on both sides of the aisle
so to say right so both the technical
people that deal with data
and the people that interpret the data
that understand where the data came from
okay so for any other questions about
the types of
project examples and resources that
we'll
be using i recommend looking at
the edu that t-bioinfo platform that's
a repository of courses and projects and
you will be able to see here a variety
of different resources
all being included in this program that
include
epigenetic epigenomic data metagenomic
data genomic and transcriptomic
as well as some of the courses on bio ml
or machine learning for biomedical data
as well as some introductory
bioinformatics courses i'm not going to
go
today through all of these different
resources but you will see
on the program which is a
place where you can find all of these
repositories
all of these different resources once
you complete
your registration and you're a part of
this program you'll be able to see
how they are all organized right here
under courses so if you go under courses
you'll be able to find
what courses are included what projects
are included
and how this program will help us go
through all of these different steps
to learn about these different skills so
today
we're just starting out with omix an
introduction to data types and
properties
as you continue we will start talking
about in detail
some of the specific steps of processing
this data
then we will go on to talk about coding
how to load
and process the data as well as filter
out unwanted variation
and understand an overview of what's in
the data
and continue on to then speak about
exploratory data analysis and
visualization
then we will talk about how to actually
design a full script that goes from
one step to the next and what are some
of the outputs
that you will expect to find and then we
will talk about
machine learning so we'll dedicate a
whole session on to machine learning and
artificial intelligence which of course
are very important today in biomedical
research
we'll talk about statistical analysis
and how to do biological interpretation
of identified features and variation
and then we will talk about supervised
and unsupervised machine learning
as well as production how to actually do
validation
of your model and how to make sure that
the type of
insights you're producing are valid and
reproducible so we'll talk about all of
these different
parts of it and so this is kind of a
brief
overview of what you will expect to see
now let's turn to the final
area that i think is going to be very
important
for all of you that are joining us this
platform so
as you probably know data science
for biologists is the pretty big
jump right so if i'm a biology student
or my clinician i am actually going to
be
interested in all of these topics but i
might have doubts am i actually going to
be able to jump in and do this myself
right what are the technical
requirements that are needed
if you are an engineering student you're
interested in data science
you probably know that many people that
speak about data science are going to be
talking about
different coding languages okay so this
is a survey
from indeed.com that was done in july
2018 so about a couple years ago
and you can see here that one of the
prominent languages in data science
is going to be python the second one by
rating is
r and so there are two things here right
so one
for people that don't know any coding
how do i even get started
right for people that know coding it's
what language should i be proficient in
this program is not going to be about
programming
this program is going to be about data
science
so with the outbreak of data science
revolution there's now a
war between our enthusiasts and python
fanatics
and people start to compare and contrast
them
a thousand times with detailed listings
of their respective advantages and
weaknesses
and so this warfare actually leads to
this misconception
that maybe as a data scientist or
someone that wants to do
data science you should always focus on
either one or the other and this is
actually
bad advice so the key to becoming a data
science professional
or to learn how to use data science for
your needs
is not to focus on one particular method
of doing this but it's actually to focus
on
data science being able to work with
data being able to ask
questions of data and being able to work
using data together with other people so
to make it reproducible
visual and insightful so that's why
here we will not focus on the specifics
of the different languages and this is
by the way in 2019
but actually to be able to use it as a
biologist
as a technician as a person who is just
interested to be able to get started so
let me show you how we're going to
achieve this okay and this is again not
going to be for
anyone that is just interested in data
science but we're going to be focused on
data science
for biological data so
please come with me to
uh comics to code omixlogic.com
okay this is the site where you can also
uh thank you beepset
uh play this is our coding playground
this is where anyone can
get started very quickly and learn how
to program enough
to be dangerous in biology and life
sciences okay so please let me know once
you're here
this is the main site that you would go
to
okay this is free registration again
uh let me show you the the registration
itself
you just put in here an email address
and a password
okay and once you do that
you will be asked to put in your credit
card details again this is
not going to be used up until you start
getting into more advanced courses and
if you join the program
you'll actually receive a discount code
that you'll be able to do for free
okay did anyone um
let me know once you're here on this
link
i've been
um okay glory thank you avidil jabar
um if you have registered again this is
a free registration you should be able
to see what i'm seeing now
okay i'll just please let me know once
you're here
and i'll just quickly review the
questions here posted
how this data science course is
different from other data science
courses for a non-biology student
again once we have the structured data
the model building going to be the same
with data from other sections like
financial data
more or less you'll use a lot of similar
approaches
but you need to understand both where
the data came from so what does it
describe
and what are the insights mean right so
that's the challenge
specifically with biological data it's
not the actual process
it's understanding where the data came
from and how do you actually report and
analyze the data to make it biologically
meaningful or
actionable for clinical insights
okay is that the same algorithm used in
other data sciences also used for values
more or less that
actual analytical or machine learning
approaches they will be very similar
but there's a lot of variation just
based on the type of data
okay okay did anyone
was anyone successful at getting to
omixlogic.com forward slash courses
okay let me know once you're here we'll
actually do an exercise together
all right excellent for those of you
that are here
let's go on to introduction to data
science in
r
okay so once you're in this course
let's go to how to load data and check
for variable
types
now these courses are going to go from
very basic
to more and more advanced as you go
through the program
so first in r you can import
directly from the code section simply by
writing
an import code so again this is a
function
that tells our program to load in some
files stored on your computer or stored
somewhere on the web and
tell us what's inside okay so let's do
that together
here we have a number of possible data
types that we will be
importing for again for example we can
take a txt
file or we can take an excel file
or we can take a csv file and you can
see that we are creating
an object a data frame
and we are inputting that file now based
on what's in the file
we need to specify sometimes if there's
a header
and maybe what type of a separation
there is
okay so this is a very simple procedure
intended to get you started
okay even before you start setting
things up on your computer
you can do it right here inside these
little exercises so for example here's
a link to a txt file okay
so let's do that together you can see
this is the code block it's editable
okay i can say here anything
i want okay when i use the hashtag this
is the way to
comment out what i'm writing
and what you need to do here you can see
that the code is just to read a table
but this is a path on my computer
so instead of this path on my computer
what i need to do is i need to
copy this link which is a file that is
not on my computer
replace this portion right here with
that link
okay and then click on run
okay let's see probably
i did something wrong
okay so there you go
all right so we ran this code
and we have here
flower different types of flowers
and the tree and the bird right so we
have some biological data here that
we've
analyzed or we've loaded sorry we've
loaded some biological data
we can look of course at what this data
is
okay so let's take a look the this is
what the data set looks like
and this is what indeed this little
program
loaded for me okay so try and go through
the rest of them you'll see that there
are multiple types
of data you can specify different things
and you can also try with a number of
different data sets here below so each
lesson that we will do
you will actually going to go into
specific
pieces of code try them out right
here and also eventually we'll talk
about how to set up your developer
environment
on your computer and start incorporating
all of these different snippets of
scripts
after i do it i can just copy it
okay copy to my clipboard and go to my
rstudio or my visual studio to
run it in r or python
okay so importantly here
the central place for this program is
your omics logic data science area
where you will see the sessions you will
see the courses
and also please explore the forum
on the forum you will start seeing
additional tutorials being posted
about how to start with r and python
on your computer how to leverage the
different resources
that we have so you can see that mohit
mazum there here posted
some tutorials on getting started with
aaron python
so please review some of this material
because in our next sessions we're going
to be doing this
together quite a lot okay let me leave
you with this
this is an assignment for our next time
that we meet
okay number one complete your profile on
edu dot t bio info
okay so please complete your profile
what is a complete profile
please use your full name please add an
avatar or a picture of yourself
links to your social media sites and
your research media sites research gate
you know work id things like that
okay explore server.tbioinfo and
code onyxlogic.com we'll be relying on
these
platforms and we'll talk a little bit
more about what these data science
platforms are designed to do they are
designed to do
analysis okay yes any code editor is
going to be
useful we will first do everything
together we can actually track
all of the activity on the code
omixlogic.com
helping address any technical issues
that you have
okay for those of you that don't have
any technical issues
great you don't need that you don't you
can use it directly on your computer
what we will work in in the sessions are
the codenomicslogic.com
rstudio and visual studio for python
okay where to find those so you can see
here install
r and r studio and or python and vs
visual studio code on your computer okay
so these resources
are posted on the forum
okay so for those of you that are going
to continue with us in our next sessions
please make sure that all of this is
ready for our next session now let me
briefly tell you
what you will learn and what is the
schedule so everyone
is familiar with the schedule today we
talked briefly about data types and
properties was a very brief introduction
i hope you found it useful
we will then continue to talk about
different types of big data what are
some of the challenges and opportunities
where to find this data
how to load this data and what can we
actually gain
from analyzing the different data data
sets
we will then talk about the independent
steps of cleaning
loading and processing the data we'll
run some pipelines
we'll give you an example that example
will come from genomics one
transcriptomics one metagenomics one
you'll see how
similar analysis approaches will produce
different types of results
once you have the data loaded we'll talk
about exploratory data analysis
so we'll talk about how to explore
what's in our data
and make some statistical uh some
statistical
um conclusions about what we have
and we'll finalize the first week of the
program
about with handling large and complex
data
so then we'll talk about introduction to
machine learning and ai
unsupervised machine learning supervised
machine learning
talk about model accuracy and validation
and how to go from
learning about this to actual production
how do you become
proficient and professional with what
you do
finally i want to mention that many of
you might
come from an area of clinical research
biological research
and other areas of life sciences we have
many participants that have successfully
completed these programs and have gained
valuable insights about what they can do
with their own data how can they make
their research more
impactful all of our participants
and we have you know several hundred
that are already a part of the different
social media groups
beeps thank you for posting those link
links we have them on
facebook we have them on linkedin please
join those groups
we we will interact with you there we
will also help
facilitate any connections that you
might want with
industry or research professionals we
also have a
an expanded research fellowship program
that you're welcome to explore
these are designed to help those that
are getting started
with bioinformatics to apply
bioinformatics to different types of
projects
again anyone who's interested to
understand what are the differences
between this program and other programs
on data science and bioinformatics
please explore
on our blog we have a few reviews
by people that have done both so you'll
see
what they think the differences are and
you'll see what people might be gaining
from these programs again thank you all
for joining today
i'm going to open it up for questions if
you have any questions
about registration uh beeps is happy to
answer those you can reach her at
marketing at pine.bio if you have any
questions about what we covered today
please put them in the chat for me or
post them on the forum if you're already
a part of the program
if you're interested to understand what
kinds of projects we're going to be
going through and using in this program
we have dr mohit mazumdar and dr
harpreet khaor
they both have phd's and bioinformatics
in different domains and chemo
informatics and in
cancer genomics so you're welcome to ask
any questions for those as well
do we have an internship program yes a
research fellowship program
could be used for an internship as well
if you're a student
and you have a requirement for an
internship
please fill out the fellowship request
and you will find the different options
there
all right well thank you again for
joining today
um i have another uh session coming up
and thank you for joining and for all of
your questions
i was happy to learn that so many of you
are interested
in data science in machine learning and
data mining and please do
email us and reach out to us
unfortunately this session
was only scheduled for an hour and a
half but we will
be excited to see you again our next
session
is coming up so again our next session
is going to be
on october 13th
i believe that is incorrect it's going
to be
on uh october 14th
so please do join us we'll be looking
forward to
seeing you and have a great rest of your
day